[Music]
good morning to everyone so my name is
Maria and I'm working at Nestle at the
Nestle IT innovation department in a
very specific team that it's called
conversational artificial intelligence
and today I'm gonna give you some
information or information in context on
what we have been doing on chat BOTS
some learning some use cases and then
going into how are we tackling the
performance the chatbots performance
through instant detection so the agenda
is going to be this one more or less
first first of all a little bit of
Nestle why are we doing that it's not
only chocolate is not only coffee and
then going to the the chibok
performances
you know itself so yes Nespresso news
covered the gusto we're also doing kaha
raha chocolate but we are also investing
on on digital it might be new for you
because actually the first half inverse
ona was created in 2016 operation
started in March so it's pretty new
however the we are pretty big team
around 200 digital experts with several
from several nationalities so the idea
of that as as a bit of context is each
market with that which is it eight
country had their own technical agency a
local one so if let's say Nestle infant
nutrition in Mexico wanted to develop an
app or a website they would go locally
with their own technical agency without
sharing a new knowledge without sharing
any learnings and doing that that
locally so the idea that came from the
management was to build this hub that
basically provides digital knowledge and
then and to the 12 national markets
basically to reduce cost efficiency and
share knowledge so basically if someone
wants to build an application a mobile
application or website they go to this
verse on hub they have selected some
technologies that they have to you
so that then it's it's easier it's
faster the time to market and also it's
cheaper at the same time so there's a
pretty strong diversity in terms of
gender Rollins and the average age is 32
and inside this global digital hub we
have the conversation artificial
intelligence here you can see some
numbers we have been working on chat
bots and boys the skills since 2016 so
we have build more than 20 tablets some
of these are live some of these are the
commission because they didn't work
obviously but from there we gather
learnings we also assess several vendors
because at the end of the day we need to
work globally so we're working with
Vietnam with Philippines with Mexico
with the US so it doesn't always work
for for the user for the US and from
Mexico or for Vietnam so we need to
actually look globally and then we have
to cover as many languages and consumer
channels as possible so some learnings
that we've gathered you can see in this
light but as an overview we realized
that the strong technology is not good
enough so strong natural language
processing engine is not only the good
thing that only thing that you need but
you also need a good conversation design
without that if you want to actually
reach this natural conversation with
your consumer you need UX designers to
help you with with within that stage
also a good NLP day is actually doing a
pro printing classification is
recommended and that's why we also look
to Google's or Microsoft because of
their broad maps but sometimes those
doesn't cover the languages that we
needed so we have to go local we also
realized that some of this platform just
provide very basic analytics so we had
to go to other sources such as Facebook
if the time if the tablet was on
Facebook Google Analytics and then kind
of understand those metrics and come up
with an overview of those so we are
actually investing on an analytic
strategy as well for tablets we are
merging those sources and analytics and
visualizing that and I
unique platform so we don't have to jump
from one to another one another thing
that we'll realize is languages so we
had to go to look into a local NLP
providers to see the for instance China
in Japan they're pretty buns and we had
some issues with dialogue flow which is
Google's an LP or with Luis so we had to
actually compare with other ones and the
consumer channel so we can not only
focus on Facebook and website which is
their the main the main ones which are
buds what we also had to go to WeChat or
kick or line because we actually are
serving Nestle brands globally and the
last thing is that Nestle is pretty
complex so integrating with NASA systems
is not an easy thing we have our own CRM
systems delivery providers so we learn
from that and we actually decided to
implement our own strategy or solution
let's say so the first thing we did is
basically because we want natural
conversations with on one guided
conversations as you might been
experiencing with some chat BOTS we
build the conversation as a graph which
basically means that I can start with
the chat bot talking about how to set up
a machine for an espresso but then I
realized that I actually want to buy
some coffee capsules or that I want to
find the nearest store to buy those
capsules so instead of starting again
from the main menu I can jump within
flows I can gather that context I store
that and then anticipate what the
consumer might might want in the future
then because we don't want to just stay
with one NLP mainly because of language
reasons we want to be enough and opium
agnostic we designed that modularized
and we use architecture to build service
on top of that as well and then we also
build the power bi dashboard that
actually combines several metrics we
basically wanted to experiment and with
the learnings that we gathered a new
approach more natural more reusable and
at the end we are building shirts shared
libraries so basically if a market or if
a country just wants to use the power bi
dashboard without
for itself they can use it if they want
to use an integration with an atlas
system they can use it they can use all
our solution they can just use a part of
it some use cases so with this new
approach we actually have a global
tablet for Nescafe which Augusto on
facebook Messenger what means a global
tablet so we have a unique Facebook page
for all Nescafe Dolce Gusto markets so I
want to highlight here the complexity of
first understanding language so if
someone from China and asked about you
gusta comes or from Vietnam or from
Mexico we need to understand the
language the intention and that's not
easy because we don't have separate
tablets that we can say this one is in
Spanish this one is in English and then
the complexity of integrating with our
local CRM systems so this chart is
basically helping you through different
complex dialogues so not only a fake use
but it's actually rather browsing how to
set up a machine machine troubleshooting
but for instance some very specific
things that we denta files such as my
drink is not hot enough so can you help
me it's not my machine is not working
which can be like a very wide range of
of obvious cases so the thing here is
the tablet can help you with all these
things that you can see there however if
it's not able to help you it will hand
over to live it so basically within the
same conversation we integrated with
Salesforce which is our CRM system an
agent comes within the conversation it
helps the consumer once it's finished we
create the case with but basically we
stored all the conversation from the
consumer details name email and so on
and then the consumer can keep chatting
with with the bot which is called melody
in this case you can see some matrix
here this what has been just life for a
month without promotion so very basic
but it actually it actually works very
well going back to the modernist
architecture I was mentioning before so
for this specific one we are building a
machine learning model
- actually densify coffee machines so
there is a specific flow within this bot
that is asking the consumer what kind of
machine do you have in order to solve
the problem what happens is that
consumer sometimes don't know the
Machine model so you basically take a
picture of your machine and then we
identify for you the Machine model and
then you can keep chatting with the
blood so that's something that um we are
experimenting and then another thing is
um a spam classifier so basically once
the but when the consumer is chatting
with the bot we open a case on our CRM
system with all the information some
sometimes they just let's say try it a
small chat or annoy the bot such as how
are you how's the weather I love you you
are not being helpful these will be kind
of conversations that we would mark as
the spam so basically we would not send
this to our CRM system because we don't
want to store our information but that's
something as well that we are working on
another use case is no same for
nutrition that was specific for
Philippines basically it helps women who
are pregnant throughout the pregnancy
estate solving very basic epic use but
as well nutritional advice and other
kind of questions that they might have
and also the handover to the live agent
exists so as you can see most of our use
cases are coming from the call centers
team because what they want to do is to
automate content to free up time from
the agents and be there 24/7 and this is
how how tablets can help our our markets
and our brands okay that was very
interesting an overview but how are we
actually working on improving that type
of performance or what are we doing that
it might be interesting for you the
first thing is we want to talk with
consumers with humans right so we have
to be as natural as possible we have to
understand the consumers language and we
have to understand their needs so the
first thing we need to do is be good at
the basics like we need to understand
these conversations and identify the
main tension so the main the main thing
that the user wants to talk or to us
sometimes it's very basic it's
is in that in the sense that they type
keywords but sometimes they randomly
type a very big paragraph with several
things and you need to define the main
intention behind that how can we do that
or what do we need so we need a very
accurate an LP enjoy that helps us to
understand this main intention and then
what we need to actually do how can we
achieve that is once we are designing
the put dialog so on let's say on the
pre-roll life phase where we design all
the conversation we should have
identified the intentions and then the
transience associated to this intention
intense once we have does since the NOP
is a classifier as any good classifier
we need a very huge training set and the
the more data we have the better the
query will be right so we need to work
on that as well together with the UX
designers and to not just rely on two or
three sentences that might help me to
understand this intention and with this
information what we need to do is or
what we're doing right now is training
this design up here what happens if it
doesn't work if we actually don't invest
time on doing that I'm pretty sure
you've seen very robotic conversations
such as you have to click on on buttons
or the user is typing things and the
body's not understanding those that's
something that is currently happening a
lot and brands do not actually focus or
they don't actually think it's important
enough if it's it's good that consumers
come to us once but even better if they
if they come twice right so one thing we
need to focus on on is on this natural
conversation instead of a guided
dialogue what do I mean by that so we
can have a very complex case and
dialogue which is this one is Nescafe
low to gustas I can either let the user
go within the last part of the dialogue
that they want so for instance my
machine is leaking and I need help or I
can tell them okay you have to go first
to the first button then I will ask you
to select the other one
and so on and finally after ten minutes
of interaction when the consumer is very
angry I deliver the appropriate response
so that's something we should invest on
and we are actually looking at so not
only not telling the consumers you have
to start from the scratch or you have to
start from the main menu but actually
going directly to the main point the
second point is about the analysis and
visualization of that performance so
most of the technologies out there what
they do is actually provide your
dashboard which they say I've been
classified classified intense or these
haven't been actually classified
properly so that it's something that we
have yes but it's something that is not
helping us to identify if if this have
been properly classified so that's
something that we actually are working
on as well I'm pretty sure you have
identified that platform is chat based
from Google basically the challenge here
is the correct classification so how do
we know that these returns was
classified to the appropriate intent I
know it is just going to the another one
right so so this platform is giving us
some extra layers where we can actually
see where consumers are dropping off
from the conversation so we we start
with the Welcome and then we have the
main intent and then we keep chatting
and we keep discovering so probably if a
lot of users drop off after one intent
it might be that we didn't actually
train that intern with appropriate to
trances or that we didn't understand the
consumer very well and we need to work
there and with platforms such as dialog
flow or any other ones we cannot see
that in the baby killing we have to use
other ones still there's a lot of work
to the very important word on this on
these false positives and it's something
that most of the companies are not
working on right now other things I
would like to mention and that we're
doing is some features that you might
want to use for each other such as the
a/b testing
so for instance we can select an NLP it
can be Louise it can be dialogue flow
don't the one that you prefer the most
and then let's say we have a new flow or
a new feature that we want to test
without consumers the thing that we can
do is actually present so have one with
this feature this new flow with the new
intense and me.we trances another one
that doesn't include that and then
present that to the consumers and see
which one is performing better and then
we select this I know P and then we work
on that we train it and then we launch
it that's something that we work a
business person asked about the gusto so
the main brands along with Purina in the
US and it's working pretty well so far
so with the courage you to use that and
another another feature is the user
feedback what do I mean by that so what
I can do is either go to the chat bot
training tab or the conversations tab
and review all the conversations
manually and I can say for instance this
conversation was correctly understood by
the bot
therefore the answer was actually the
appropriate one or I can ask the
consumer to tell me that because
sometimes is even better and more
accurate so we can include the question
after the chat bot conversation and as
the consumer did I hope you correctly
with the question you had yes or no so
you can do that a Dra
at the very end of the conversation or
you can do that after some specific
intents to do some kind of training on
just those one so let's say you have two
very close it's very similar and you
want to actually see if those are
performing good so then you would
deliver the question there and then if
you want you can also add a metric to
your to your dashboard so you can either
add these on your both performance
metric you can add a separate one so the
one that you can see in the screen is
something that we can do it for we are
doing for NDG mucho gusto so we're
actually actually looking if consumers
are happy or not
with the chat bot performance and then
we are investigating why because
sometimes people just click randomly
yes/no - just keep chatting with the
boss so another thing that we can do is
tell me
why you weren't happy just to see if
it's that they were not happy or they
just selected the button randomly then
another thing that you can do to improve
your chatbot is what we call it official
chances so I'm pretty sure that if I ask
you right now how would you ask for
coffee Twitter but we can come up with
20 different ways of saying that there's
no just one unique way so what we can
use is these natural language generation
services where we give one sentence and
they automatic create hundreds of
sentences of different ways to say that
so you can say I want to buy coffee I
just ran out the point - press o or
espresso I need to go to the shop and
buy some capsules there are several ways
and we need to identify all possible
ones or at least I would say 70% of the
possible ones before combing life
otherwise we're going to fail at the
basics so this is an example that we use
for Nespresso so we actually used a
company to generate around 200 of
several sentences on how to this gallon
machine it can be useful dialogue flow
is very good but we also wanted to
tackle this a specific problem or
basically if I need coffee there are
several ways of saying that some of
these are already covered by by us and
the market and you can come up with
these ideas but some of the times you
don't know also it's very specific to
market to the market so what we usually
do is once we have these sentences we
ask the market so for instance English
English you can say there's just one way
to ask for things but if you go to the
UK they will say oh no the US are going
to say it in a completely different way
so then you need some time from the
market there as well to customize to the
tone of voice or to the brand voice as
well these sentences and why did we use
that for Nespresso and Escovedo gusta
basically because we wanted to save time
instead of asking the market to type the
sentence manually we did that first step
for them and then they just tweaked and
adapted the phrase they would rent
and then because we wanted to increase
the effectiveness on the training and
performance face so we wanted to
accelerate this time to market lunch and
then that I think is the topic
extraction so there's one way to
identify how tablets didn't understand
the consumers and this is going to the
default intent right do you go there you
see all the other conversations or
return so they weren't understood by the
bot you can do that manually I'm pretty
sure you don't want to do that manually
because it's ready tedious it's very
tiring so what we can do is extract the
text and clean the text read some
keywords so basically from data set then
you would identify the main the main
topics that the consumers are talking
about and from here you can understand
either if we you didn't cover your space
or you did but you didn't actually work
on detecting the intention behind that
so we did that for Purina
in the UK they gave us a an Excel with
all the conversations from the call
centers and we wanted to see if what the
market asked us to do for a chat bot was
what the consumers were asking for
sometimes the brand comes and says I
want to talk about that delivers a fake
use and product pricing and sometimes
consumers don't want that they just want
another epic kind of epic use that they
want another specific flows so we've
basically identified the main keywords
and we work together with a UX team to
design those flows and present that to
do that to the market into the brand so
as I as I said this can help me to
discover if I need to refine some
incense and I find some flaws add new
features so for instance the one for the
the machine model we didn't actually
include under release one but then we
saw that a lot of people were saying I
don't know my machine type my machine my
machine model so that was something that
we work on after the goal life so kind
of enhancing the board as well does
everything from my side I don't know if
you have any questions I'm here to
answer some of those if I can
thank you for your great speech
it was blessed to hear some really
useful things in our company we have we
have not a lot of experience with
chatbots
and one of the problems is that creating
chatbots require a lot of manual work we
tzatzi's the dialogue graphs I mean
sequences of intense about reaction and
the sequence how do you organize
creation of these graphs you have some
separate team which go deep into domain
and create these graphs Oh what thank
you
so we basically we don't develop
in-house we don't actually create the
flows in-house Anessa we externalize
that so we work first with a creative
team that works with the brand to
identify the main the main let's say
topic that they need to talk about and
they present a decision tree right and
then these together with a technical
team which is obviously usually it's the
same the same company they come up with
this first let's say set training set
and then they have the market validating
that so it's kind of a three teams
working on that and what we do is
basically a subject matter experts we
kind of give some guidance on the but we
in-house we don't develop this you
explain for a team how to use for
example some specific markup and make
this dialogues right but it's not a
developer rock right no it's a
combination of several thank you yeah
yeah thanks for the talk
have you consider or tried instead of a
chat Bottas interface where people write
providing an interface where people
select or type what are they what are
they issues so because we have tried
that at anybody here on we saw that it's
working better that other approaching in
which instead of asking the customer
what do you want if you just provide I
want a coffee and then you allow people
to say
or click I want a country we have seen
at least for us that is more fitting way
for for customers to say what they want
so you basically have their the answers
and the consumers yeah links with
different flows and also weaker we have
created like the flow of the
conversation but instead of identifying
by the customers writing what they want
we provide them the flow try that or
consider it yeah we did in the rain
initial station in 2016 when we launched
the first step but they were very guided
but we also gave the option as for free
text to the consumers because even
internally when we were developing the
tab or let's say my final client is not
my kind is not the consumer is Nespresso
ok so basically I build the bot for them
if I present them tablet that is just
guided one they will basically say that
they don't want it because they will be
the first testers and they want to chat
with the bus so we we did that for
promotions basically for promotions it
works pretty well because usually they
are temporary so for Christmas or I
don't know Black Friday and it's a very
limited scope right so you say I only
can help I can only help you with
promotions on ABC and then this is what
the bot can do and I'm actually telling
you that this is what I can do so don't
ask me anything else and it works better
but when you are giving a lot of let's
say products or a lot of options to the
user they prefer to do that as pretext
at least from what we've seen so far but
it might be a good option as well we can
investigate that further yeah it's
another question are you measuring like
the bounce rate because I didn't see it
on this like say yeah yeah yeah I mean I
just put there actually I didn't put any
screenshot from our power bi dashboard
that where that was from another another
but yeah we have three taps and we have
the bounce rate as well yeah thank you
I was thinking together with a - with
the chatbot and with some most recent
technology development and also some of
the real-life experience for example if
I go to a website I saw some chat BOTS
trying to talk to me I just ignore it
because that's not sounds like human
this is machine I know it but if you ask
me to call somebody to call the service
lady or service man is good if you if
there is an actual person who I want to
type too it's also good I mean if I ask
myself why I'm not really willing to
talk to us about
I know it's dead I'm not willing to talk
to him or or that the machine but if I
ask myself under what kind of
circumstances I can talk to this thing
if this thing can speak so I'm thinking
you know if the first time when there's
a chance for greetings this part can say
hi you know I am I'm whom right I and I
would like to serve your something do
you have any questions for me so this
thing can probably already increase user
experience mix at least a mix me feel
this sounds more like a human I have
more intention talking to this thing
even though it can be annoying in the
beginning I'm just thinking you know
that's the first thing and second thing
in the smart speakers if there could be
some connections to smart speakers like
go go home echo so this could make you
know together with your development
there with speech at least a fro human
it sounds more natural to speak for
example when my cooking there in the in
the kitchen one or I'm doing something
else I could speak at the same time for
example driving I could speak at the
same time but it cannot actually typing
at the same time yeah these are very
good questions so the third thing is
that maybe with the VRA our thing that
can virtualize a lady or a or a man
talking in front of me it makes me feel
more like that's a human instead of a
machine at that machine talking to me so
that may make your chat bot more useful
so that's some of my personal feeling
yeah ok so just very briefly so
regarding a year we haven't done
anything yet we are just doing some PSAs
but anything like regarding smart
speakers that's very interesting because
we had the use case for recipes as you
mentioned so you have a tablet for
recipes in Mexico where you can actually
while you're waiting I don't know
doctors are just going to work or going
back home you can look for recipes
depending on your level cooking level of
expertise if you are cooking for two or
three people and then allergies and then
it selects you or you present you a set
of recipes then what it does is the
shopping list so you then you go to the
supermarket and then once you get home
if you have an echo show it drives you
or it works you throughout the recipe
steps so basically your cooking
hands-free you don't have to use the
chat but you use the echo show to go
through that recipe so that's a very
interesting use case as well the one
that you mentioned but agree that
usually once you build either a table or
a voice skill you need to make sure that
you present what the boat can do first
to manage expectations and then to sound
as natural as possible however I think
we're getting there it's very difficult
to actually sound very very natural and
being able to understand everything at
the first at the first ones so I
actually had a question about your
performance metric so in lieu of asking
customers for direct feedback of whether
the conversation was helpful what are
some indirect ways you've looked at that
so I'm sorry um so how you've looked at
whether the the chat bot was performing
well
so you mentioned asking customers to
right away if it was helpful so if
you're not able to collect that data
what are you using to gauge that so
sometimes if we have the email because
they have shared it we can go back and
ask what didn't work right now I agree
we don't ask the reason I mean there's
kind of a nonsense right but sometimes
it helps us to understand if it's very a
pattern that it's the similar maybe
we're not capturing the intent correctly
so we will need to work on the trunk
maybe in that and that I have a similar
question especially when you're testing
two different models how do you decide
which model to move forward with huh
that's a good question let me think
so usually usually that way I architect
was sitting there but I'm not gonna make
him reply it and that because he's gonna
kill me but basically we rely on them to
tell us which works better but usually
it's basically the way so if we need to
follow a lot of steps to get somewhere
usually it doesn't work because
consumers want it right away that's one
thing that we measure and then as well
other things that maybe you can chat to
Enrique because I don't have the all the
other context there sorry about this
[Music]